[Música]
qual é a função social da universidade
eu gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
uma história de superação
protagonizado por um grupo de mulheres
de uma associação rural do município de
gurinhatã que fica no interior do estado
de minas gerais
e se esse grupo de mulheres é liderado
pela dona terezinha essa senhora que
está no canto e da foto
e esse município fica tem 5639
habitantes de acordo com o censo e 2019
fica a 70 quilômetros do município de
ituiutaba onde nós temos um câmpus da
universidade federal de uberlândia ea
200 quilômetros da cidade de uberlândia
onde fica a nossa sede
esse grupo de mulheres artesãs produz um
bordado muito requintado chamado i chile
esse bordado exige uma técnica muito
apurada que muita paciência e muita
precisão e o produto final como vocês
podem ver é simplesmente uma obra de
arte
a dona terezinha veio nos procurar na
universidade buscando apoio para
viabilizar a produção ea comercialização
desse bordado dessa desse grupo de
cooperados no contexto da geração de
trabalho e renda e da economia solidária
depois do projeto elaborado buscou-se
aprovação de um financiamento desse
projeto foram feitos vários cursos de
formação de cooperativismo de economia
solidária
trabalhamos vários aspectos na área de
gestão na área administrativa
e aqui nós podemos ver um exemplo das
produções coletivas que eram
na região conhecida como santa cruz o
temeroso onde as cooperadas trabalhavam
bordavam juntas e usavam esse tempo pra
discutir os mais variados assuntos
inclusive os familiares
vejo depois de meses de produção
primeiro a oportunidade de venda e
comercialização de seus produtos
a dona terezinha nos comunica que o
ônibus dela tinha sido assaltado e toda
a produção tinha sido roubada
imagine a tristeza ea frustração nas
palavras dela
no outro dia de manhã o meu filho
nós perdemos tudo mas estamos bem graças
a deus
nessa hora a única coisa que eu consegui
falar foi dona terezinha
deus sabe o que faz ea senhora que só
quer fazer há a meu filho eu quero
recomeçar e nós que começamos aqui tá
dona terezinha no estande de vendas em
belo horizonte
na foto de baixo dá um prémio numa feira
de artesanato que ela ganhou liberava
fazendo o bordado de um de um berço em
regime e e aqui estão os outras
informações da premiação e outras
premiações que ela recebeu o projeto
finalizou
o grupo tomou outros rumos já se
passaram quase dez anos ea lição
continua guardada no meu coração e o que
possibilitou essa parceria entre a
associação de artesãs ea universidade é
a extensão que é um processo de
transformação social
de acordo com o forex de 2003 o conceito
de extensão é a atividade acadêmica
capaz de imprimir um novo rumo à
universidade brasileira e de contribuir
significativamente para a mudança da
sociedade contribuir significativamente
para a mudança da sociedade
além da dona terezinha
temos vários outros projetos que são
desenvolvidos não só dentro da
incubadora mas como tempo da
universidade como um todo
projetos na área de agricultura familiar
projetos na área de fruticultura aqui em
patos de minas
projetos na área de formação de detentos
em regime fechado em uberlândia projetos
na área de formação de jovens
programadores na área de informática e
monte carmelo e um projecto de apoio à
formação do comitê paraolímpico
brasileiro lá em uberlândia
esses projetos podem ser visualizados
nesta tabela dos dados de 2018
se nós olharmos só o campus daqui de
patos de minas
nós podemos relatar que nós temos três
programas 13 projetos em 10 cursos e
eventos e aproximadamente seis mil e
quinhentas pessoas envolvidas
se nós falarmos da faculdade de gestão e
negócios que a unidade acadêmica com
pertenço
nós temos quatro programas 31 projetos
58 cursos e mais de 28 mil pessoas
envolvidas ea uff como todo os números
são 58 programas 457 projetos 960 cursos
eventos e dois milhões e 400 mil pessoas
envolvidas
agora se nós já hoje fazemos muita
extensão o que nós podemos entender a
partir da implementação do plano
nacional de educação
esse plano 2014 2 24 ele tem uma meta
muito especial
essa meta é assegurar que no mínimo 10%
do total de créditos curriculares
exigidas para a graduação em programas e
projetos de extensão universitária
orientando sua ação prioritariamente
para áreas de grande pertinência social
projetos para a área de grande
pertinência social 10% de toda a carga
horária de todos os cursos de graduação
imagine se hoje já o flu já faz muita
extensão quando nós conseguimos
implementar
aqui em patos de minas os nossos três
cursos os nossos 5326 os nossos 39
técnicos e os nossos 5 522 estudantes ea
uff como um todo os nossos 97 cursos os
nossos mais de dois mil docentes e 3 mil
técnicos e os nossos mais de 24 mil
estudantes fazendo extensão projetos
sociais pertinentes e promovendo a
transformação social que pensemos mais
que o brasil
segundo os dados do censo da educação de
nós temos 34 mil 376 conste graduação
distribuídos entre públicos e privados e
mais de oito milhões de estudantes
matriculados 8 milhões de estudantes
trabalhando em pedaços do seu tempo em
projetos em prol da comunidade em prol
da sociedade em prol do brasil mas pra
isso nós precisamos dois pontos chaves
que são fundamentais o primeiro aqui
convidamos a comida à comunidade como a
t toda teresina nos procurou e nos traga
os seus problemas nos traga suas
propostas no sábado seus o que nós
podemos ajudá los e no segundo ponto
chave é internamente tenta universidade
nós precisamos entender que o nosso
conhecimento só tem sentido se for bem
se for bem da população e se for bem da
comunidade
pessoalmente falando eu posso dizer que
quem participa de projetos de extensão
se torna um profissional melhor
um profissional mais completo mais
sensível mais responsável
se paulo freire nos este novo e quem
educa se educa a extensão nos mostra que
quem transforma primeiramente transforma
um profissional melhor e no profissional
mais humano
aqui eu gostaria de agradecer
a dona da dona terezinha por tudo aquilo
que eu aprendi e por tudo aquilo que ela
me ensinou e agradecer a ufu pela
oportunidade e agradecer a todos vocês
[Aplausos]